imagine you're at a party there are a
couple of dozen guests what are the
chances that two of them will have the
same birthday the answer is better than
even
if the party had 60 guests then chances
would be greater than 99
it's an example of how we often are too
impressed by coincidences because we
forget about how many ways there are for
coincidences to occur
[Music]
the tendency to see meaningful
connections between completely unrelated
things is what psychologists call
apophenia it means we often see patterns
in random information and this can be
deeply problematic when we hallucinate
things that aren't there
we can make foolish decisions we can
imagine that there are
conspiracies because several bad things
happen in a row
we can believe in malevolent deities
because we underestimate how easy it is
for misfortunes to cluster we can be
victims of the gamblers fallacy and
think for example that if the roulette
wheel has landed on red six times in a
row it's kind of due for a black even
though of course the roulette wheel
doesn't have a memory and a desire to
play fair the gambler's fallacy also
known as the monte carlo fallacy is the
incorrect belief that a past event will
influence the outcome of a future event
so why do so many of us fall for it the
whole point of having a brain is to
figure out what's going on in the world
now it's a useful thing in a natural
environment because we
don't have a
direct wire from our brain to reality
we're always interpreting patterns we
see shapes hidden partly obscured by
leaves we see fish under the surface of
the water we always go beyond the
information given but it does mean that
we can
overshoot and interpret things that
aren't actually there
not just in the realm of visual shapes
but in the realm of events this failure
to appreciate randomness can lead to all
sorts of problems it can lead some
people to dismiss climate change after a
record cold day when in fact if they
were able to step back and look at the
overall trend it would be clear that it
was a completely normal if random
fluctuation and that can lead us to a
tribute meaning to totally unrelated
life events when events happen randomly
in time
they often fall into clusters because
there is no process that's trying to
space them apart that's something that
that is very hard for us to appreciate
now when it comes to events in our lives
that might be distributed randomly in
time from the perspective of our minds
seeking patterns they seem to come into
clusters and so we may believe that bad
things happen in threes
that god is testing our faith
that we're born under a bad sign another
common illusion is prior probability
sometimes called the texas sharp shooter
fallacy after the marxism he fires a
bullet into the side of a barn and then
draws a bullseye around the hull
afterwards there's the story about the
stock market advisor who sends out
several thousand newsletters half of
which predict that the market will go up
and half predicted it'll go down he then
discards the
names on the mailing list who happen to
get the incorrect prediction well you
can see where this is going after a year
there'll be a certain remainder who will
think that this guy is a genius it's a
fallacy that we are all prone to it's
why we are often impressed by
psychics and soothsayers whose
predictions are amazingly accurate after
they've occurred and we tend to forget
all of the false predictions so if we
know that we are prone to falling for
these delusions to seeing patterns that
aren't there what can we do about it an
awareness that we are all vulnerable to
fallacies and illusions and biases
doesn't
mean we should just fatalistically throw
up our hands and say humans are
irrational and therefore we need some
kind of benevolent despots to make
decisions for us that democracy was a
big mistake probably none of us is that
wise that we can notice our own
fallacious thinking we're often very
better at noticing the other guy's
fallacious thinking and we can harness
that ability in communities that have
free speech open debate an adversarial
process checks and balances editing fact
checking so that one person's mistaken
first impression their illusory snap
judgment can be
spotted by someone else and the
community as a whole
implements the most reasoned decision
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video